Next question is you've alluded to that
in some of the beautiful hadith you've
mentioned just now but um what specific
reason is it that Ramadan is called the
month of forgiveness or is known as the
month of
>> yes as I rightly mentioned earlier that
our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said it's in a hadith of say
bkari number three book of fasting had
number 1901 our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said that if
anyone fasts in the month of Ramadan
with the proper intention with faith and
asking for reward of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala he will forgive all your past
sins and this message is further
repeated in the mustnat ahmed
volume number three had number 11524
where it's mentioned that any person who
fast in the month of Ramadan
with the proper intention
seeking the reward of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala
he will have all his previous sins
atoned
and further it's mentioned in say Muslim
volume number one had number 450 our
beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that the time
between the five prayers
and the two jummas and from one Ramadan
to the other is the time for expiration
of your sins. This is the time where you
can have all your sins forgiven.
And a beloved prophet wasallam also said
it's mentioned in Sai Muslim volume
number four in the book of TBA had
number 6644. Our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said that
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala at night time
a person who asks for forgiveness he
forgives the sin for the sin he has
committed in the day and Allah
subhananau wa ta'ala in the daytime he
forgives the sin for a person who asks
for forgiveness for the sin he has
committed night so this is the best
month of forgiveness the month of
Ramadan where you can easily have your
sins forgiven because the gates of
heaven open and the gates of hell are
closed. Therefore, it's called the month
of forgiveness.